oui on va tous titres reprendre la
direction de kiev où la connexion semble
être rétablie avec notre envoyé spécial
je vous le disais à cyril payen romont
jour cyril cyril on a donc récupéré la
connexion quelle est la situation je
vous le demande est alors quelle est la
situation sur place à l'heure où l'on se
parle cyril
et bien on est toujours effectivement
dans cette même rue qui est une des
allées centrales du quartier historique
de la capitale ukrainienne c'est
absolument saisissant pour les gens qui
ont peut venir ici eh bien il ya
peut-être dix jours c'était une un
samedi soir notamment un quartier et une
rue normalement noire de monde des gens
qui convergent havre des restaurants des
des familles là c'est totalement vide
nous avons traversée kiev depuis deux
heures la ville est entièrement vide il
n'y a que je ne sais pas si vous pouvez
voir derrière moi georges asbeck va
certainement vous montrer il y à des
barrages avec des milices d'autodéfense
qui sont ces miliciens d'autodéfense et
basso sur des des des riverains des
habitants des quartiers qui ont décidé
de se mobiliser pour la défense de deux
cafés cela ce genre de spectacle et bien
c'est à chaque coin de rue dans tout le
coeur de la capitale on ne croise plus
personne tous les immeubles que vous
pouvez voir tout autour de moi sont
pratiquement vides et bien cette vie
cette ville est devenue totalement
exsangues d'une partie de sa population
qui a préféré rejoindre l' exode massif
vers la frontière paul polonaise mais
aussi d'autres frontières et donc des
barricades un peu partout et l'autoroute
qui mène à à kiev est extrêmement
impressionnant il est totalement vide il
n'y a que des des barrages et des
barricades
un peu un peu partout tenue soit par des
militaires lourdement armés soit encore
une fois par ses milices d'autodéfense
et puis tous les chemins détournés rien
n'est épargné il y à une mobilisation
populaire extrêmement impressionnante on
sent que c'est vraiment toute la
population ukrainienne toute la vie de
tous les habitants de l'oblast de l'a22
de kiev c'est à dire la région
administrative de de kiev c'est ce grand
périmètre de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres carrés qui sont
résolus quoi qu'il en coûte à rester ici
depuis 10 ou dixième jour de l'invasion
russe dont nous sommes en plein coeur de
cette ville qui est totalement
transférer transformer et c'est une
ville phare nous sommes dans un quartier
historique de kiev qui est transformé
tel que vous le découvrez quand en ville
et en quartiers entiers fantômes qui
n'est tenu que par des miliciens en
armes résolus à défendre leur ville
merci beaucoup cyril payen envoyé
spécial de france 24 à kiev donc